في فبراير الماضي مشاهدينا طبقت بريطانيا
وويلز قانون الحد الادنى لسن الزواج من 16
عاما الى 18 عاما كل هذا في اطار حمايه
الفتيات القصر من الزواج القصري الان ما
تدرسه مصر في ظل ارتفاع عدد حالات الطلاق
من جهه وايضا للحد من النمو السكاني طبعا
عده مؤسسات طرحت توصيات برفع سن الزواج
لاكثر من 18 عاما يصل الى واحد وعشرين
ايضا بدا جهه حكوميه رسميه تتعاطى مع
المقترح بجديه اكبر
وافق احصائيات رسميه في مصرف كبيره من
الفتيات المطلقات قاصرات ونتج عن ذلك
زياده حالات الطلاق الى حاله كل دقيقتين
خلال العام الماضي بعدما كانت قبل 12 عاما
حاله كل سبع دقائق طبعا مشاهدينا سالنا
الناس في مصر ما هو سن الزواج الانسب في
الوقت الحالي
برايكم فاجابوا
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للسن الجواز ليه الشاب 30
والبنت 2020 23 24 كده للبنت بعد ما تخلص
جامعه مثلا قول 24 تكون بدات تعمل كارير
لنفسها وخلاص يعني بدات يعني بقى لها حياه
وكده وبعدين اقعد تفكر في الجواز الولد
اعتقد في الوقت دلوقتي يعني مش اقل من 30
خالص باي حال من الاحوال انا ابني عنده 32
سنه ومش عايز يتجوز كل ما بيسمع الاخبار
كل يوم وكده اقول لك لا طب انا اتجوز ليه
يعني بقى صعب حتى على الشباب بما ان انا
شاب يعني اعتقد مثلا 28 سنه تكون لحته
تتخرج تعمل كارير تبدا يبقى عندك شغل عندك
فلوس تعرف تجيب شقه تبدا تقدم حتى على اي
حاجه زي كده ودلوقتي البنت بقت طموحاتها
عاليه جدا يعني ممكن كمان توصل 30 وفوق
ال30 وال 35 عادي نعود لفقره مع وضد
والموضوع الجدلي حول ام مقترحات برفع سن
الزواج في مصر للحد من الطلاق وكذلك النمو
السكاني من القاهره ينضم الينا كل من
المحامي بالنقد عصام عجاج والاستشاريه في
العلاقات الاسريه الدكتور عنان حجازي اهلا
بكما لابدا اذا مع
المحامي بالنقد عصام عجل سد عصام يعني هذا
القانون هل بالفعل سيكون سببا في الحد من
اقبال الزواج على او اقبال الشباب على
الزواج وبالتالي
منع هناك قانون لعدم زواج القاصرات لكن
هذا القانون ما الهدف منه
[موسيقى]
الاعباء القضايا في المحاكم من نفقه وطلاق
وتمكين من منزل زوجيه وتمديد منقولات
زوجيه وخلافه
عايز اقول ان احنا النهارده عندنا تخيلي
لما نيجي نقول مثلا عندنا لا يقل عن
130,000 فتاه متزوجه من سن 10 لسن 17 سنه
لا هذا خمسه
يعني في قانون اعتقد في مصر
في مصر لا موجود موجود بس بيتم التحقيق يا
سيدي الفاضل موجود القانون وتم رفع سن
الزواج لحد الادنى له 18 سنه لكن بيتم
التحايل على هذا بالزواج القاصرات على
اساس ان هو بيتعمل بزواج عرفي وعشان كده
ما فيش تجريم للزواج العرفي فده سبب عشان
كده انا بانادي بان نرفع سن الزواج معين
لكن مش على اطلاقه لكن هيقابلنا مشكله في
رفع سن الزواج انا عندي مواد الدستور
بتمنع ذلك يعني عندي مواد الدستور في
القانون النهارده الدستور بيقول ان
المساواه بين الحقوق والواجبات ولا يمكن
تقييم اي حريه بالنسبه للشخص الولد او
البنت هنتكلم اي قانون يقيد حريته
لكن هناك سقف او سن للزواج هذا
لا يخل بتقييد الحريه هذا هو القانون على
كل حال هو القانون الان في مصر 18 عاما
خلينا نحكي شويه علم نفس دكتوره عنان من
ناحيه نفسيه
موجوده معنا
من ناحيه نفسيه هل هناك هذا الفرق الهائل
ما بين نضوج
وقدره القدره على تحمل المسؤوليه بالنسبه
للفتاه او للشب من 18 عاما ل 21 عام هل
هناك هذا الفلق الفرق الكبير
دكتوره
فقد الاتصال يعني
صباح الخير
نعم تفضلي
حنتكلم حضرتك بتقولي دلوقتي هل في فرق بين
اللي عمرهم 18 او 21 في ان احنا نقدم سن
الزواج
تمام كده السؤال اه مظبوط هل هناك فرق
بالوعي وقدره على تحمل المسؤوليه والنضوج
بثلاث سنوات فقط يعني
بصي حضرتك احنا قلنا زواج القاصرات ده
مرفوض كليا قانونا ونفسيا واجتماعيا لما
ناخد الزواج اللي هو بالنسبه للزواج
المبكر تمام قوي بناخد شويه اسباب لازم
تتعمل عشان الارتقاء النفسي
فقط
فقدنا الدكتور عنان حجازي الاتصال معها
سنعود اليها اذا اذا ما كانت جاهزه يبدو
ان هناك خلل يعني خليني ارجع الى عصام
استاذ عصام يعني انت اليوم تطالب بتحديد
هذا
السن ورفع السن خلينا نقول لك بانه يعني
هذا الشاب اللي سواء في الارياف سواء في
في الصعيد او حتى في المدينه ما اصحاش من
الصبح وراح اتزوج لانه هو على باله يشتري
عسليه وجبهه هذا زواج سواء 18 ولا 21 سنه
هو لديه عقل يفكر بمسؤولياته
وعشان كده انا لما جيت حتى الاخت الزميله
اللي مع حضرتك في الاستوديو بتقول ان ان
القانون احنا بنقول بننظم او خلافه لا هو
الدستور اللي بيقول كده لا يجوز لاي قانون
ان يعطل الحريات اللصيقه وده تعطيل يعني
انا بقول وبالتالي وبالتالي انت النهارده
عشان خاطر انت المفروض انك انت بتطوع
القوانين للدستور وليس تطويع الدستور
للقوانين بمعنى ان الدستور ده ابو
القوانين عشان تطلع لي انت النهارده قانون
يرفع سن الزواج ل 18 او 21 او خلافه انت
كده المفروض انك انت تغير مواد في الدستور
وانا بقولهالي لحضرتك اهوت على مسؤوليه
الماده تسعه وثلاثه والماده 53 والماده
والماده 92 انت المفروض انك انت لكن انا
عايز اقول جمله مهمه جدا مش واخدين بالكم
منها ايه هي انا مش في احتياج لقانون ليه
مش محتاج لقانون ليه انا مش محتاج لقانون
لان انا عندي اصلا في مصر في عزوف عن سن
الزواج في عزوف عن الزواج لا هذا شيء
باراده يعني هذا هذا يمكن ثقافه اخرى لكن
القانون هنا ينظم ويحدد وبالتالي الكل
سواسيه لا نتحدث عن ما يحتال عليه شكرا
جزيلا انتهى وقتنا المحامي بالنقد عصام
عجاج ربما نكون يعني في نقاش اخر حول هذا
الموضوع ايضا الشكر للدكتور عنان حجازي
الاستشاريه في العلاقات الاسريه شكرا لكما
المقادير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات